I'm going to let you in on a secret not
everything you read on the internet is
true I know it's shocking but it's the
case in fact it turns out there's a lot
of good information and then there's
some other that's not and trying to
figure out which sources are reliable
and which ones aren't is actually not
always that easy
but where do we go if we're looking for
answers well it tends to be anymore
these days we go to a search engine on
the internet and Google happens to be
one of the best of these so that's the
one that we go to probably most often so
let's take a look what would happen if
we did a search on Google and we asked
it to tell us who invented the airplane
okay you're going to see results that
look like this and it's going to get you
see a number of names there and
apologies to my friends in Brazil but
since I'm in North Carolina I'm going to
go with the Wright brothers as the
inventors not Dumont but these are the
different sources so there's some debate
and if you look through the list of
Google results you're going to see
things that are links that could be
reliable you're going to see some links
that may be fake news and you're going
to see a bunch of ads and trying to
figure out which one is which again not
always obvious also you're going to see
discussion about this controversy as to
who was actually the inventor so if
you're just looking for a quick answer
we really didn't get it there but we did
get a lot of information
now it turns out that we have newer
technology AI based technology chat Bots
that are giving us information in a much
different sort of way one of the new
ones that's really taking the Internet
by storm these days is called chat GPT
let's ask it the same question okay who
invented the airplane and we see a very
simple succinct authoritative sounding
answer we don't see a controversy we
don't see lots of links we don't see ads
we don't see fake news we don't see
there's nothing to really sort through
it's just the answer that we're looking
for well that's really attractive if I
can just ask a question and get the
answer and not have to sort through it
well look who isn't going to go for that
we're going to as these chat Bots get
better and better rely on them more and
more now this may not be a complete
replacement for search engines because
sometimes I really do want to look at
all the different sources and sort
through it but the point is we're going
to start relying probably more and more
on these kinds of sources
but what makes something reliable well
it tends to be that we look for
observability we look for the the
citation of sources and things like that
because some sources We Trust more than
we do others
but you know when when we're looking at
something like a chat Bots answer we
don't get that so there's a trade-off
here bottom line though if you look at
these two results one's really long and
I have to sort through and and pour
through all the details and do my own
thinking and the other one just tells me
is the answer what do you think most
people are going to go for the simple
answer
now that sounds great what could
possibly go wrong
let me tell you what could possibly go
wrong well so how does this stuff work
well it turns out that we have an AI
system
and the AI that is behind the chat bot
has to get its information from
somewhere so we use a knowledge base
sometimes many different sources in this
knowledge base we call a corpus
and that Corpus is what we use to train
the AI
so that then we can have a user come
along here ask a question of the AI and
get an answer back so this is the model
and that's all fine and good until
somebody decides to mess it up
somebody like this guy comes along and
says wouldn't it be fun if I corrupted
some of the information in this Corpus
what if I introduced a little bit of
wrong information and had it mixed in
with the good because if it came in with
just really really blatantly wrong
information this guy is going to detect
that but if we come in with a little bit
and just corrupt a little bit of the
results then we corrupt a little bit of
the answers and this guy ends up with
the wrong information
and as we become more and more relying
on these kinds of sources something like
this can be Insidious it slips in and
before we know it we've now made
decisions based upon bad information now
one of the popular ones of these that I
said before is called chat GPT it's a
great resource and you saw what kind of
answer it gave I'm not saying that this
has ever happened with chat GPT I'm
saying let's take a look at this as an
example and see what could happen what
if this happened in this case well in
the example I gave before we might get
the wrong answer about who invented the
airplane not the end of the world nobody
is harmed by this but what could happen
if the Corpus poisoning case led to
something more important something more
Insidious let's say I go to chat GPT and
say I want to come up with a household
cleaner just using stuff around the
house well we could do that kind of
search and if I do that I'm going going
to get back a very simple answer that
says you know what you could use baking
soda and vinegar and water and mix them
in exactly this way it's a nice formula
again I didn't have to search a thousand
links and figure out which ones to use
and which ones don't I got a simple
authoritative answer right there so
let's say I mix it up and I clean my
house great
however let's look at the case where a
bad guy snuck in a little bit of bad
information into the corpus
again not seeing this happened with chat
GPT but I'm saying it's possible with
any AI to potentially poison the Corpus
and if that were to happen what if the
formula that came out then came out and
said instead of using those ingredients
let's mix ammonia and bleach okay those
are two things you have around the house
well it turns out that's quite toxic
that's a bad result for you and it could
result in health problems for the
individual that ends up mixing these two
things together so this is just an
example I'm not saying that the world is
going to come to an end because somebody
mixed up bleach and ammonia but imagine
that example where this person is making
decisions important decisions based upon
the information in their Ai and they've
become so Reliant because this chat bot
has been so trustworthy for so long that
we end up with a problem
well this is not without precedent in
fact we've had chat Bots go Rogue before
there was a case where chatbot went on
the internet started learning the
language of the internet and the way
people interacted and within a day it
was spouting all kinds of offensive uh
things to people and had to be shut down
so again not everything that we see on
the internet is in fact true and not
everything that's true is worth talking
about so there's a filter that has to go
on so what should we expect of our AI
well we want some sort of observability
in order to create this level of
trustworthiness we want to be able to
verify in an Ideal World I'd like for
the chatbot to cite its sources so that
I can then go to those sources and
verify I'd like to even almost in a math
way say show me your work don't just
give me the answer sometimes we just
want the answer but in some cases we
really need it to show its work and a
lot of the times these systems don't do
that but we're going to need to rely on
that another example where this could
come along is with code samples you can
go into chat GPT for instance and it's
very good tell it to write you a
particular routine and it will and tell
it the language and it will give you
source code you can copy and paste it
into yours
again great stuff but what if the Corpus
was poisoned and in fact it inserts
malware or a back door into your code if
you start relying on that as your source
and all you do is say write me a code
snippet copy and paste and you don't
verify what's happening you could end up
with a program that's a disaster and not
even know about it so this is what we
have to do it's the old lesson that
we've always had when it comes to
sources trust but verify and don't stop
doing it just because it's a computer or
just because it's AI also insist on
verification
thanks for watching please remember to
like this video And subscribe to this
channel so we can continue to bring you
content that matters to you